how's it going bros my name is Pierre de
Paz de we're gonna play Google feud but
if only I had a friend to play with
hey Felix oh wow that was fast like Jack
and go slow
what's going on Oh what were you doing
there I just had your knees our friends
I thought come to your rescue thank you
I appreciate that you want to play
Google feud yeah let's do it man
should I be taller PJ my mortal enemy
what I don't want to fight we're gonna
fight it out whoever wins this there are
punishments involved okay which one you
prefer nail art Oh beautiful nails maybe
would you like a tattoo perhaps smells
good or a head hair lights why are you
talking as if it's only gonna be me why
are you saying why this is not rigged I
promise let's begin all right game PJ
will now explain the game ah click on a
category yeah you've complete the Google
sentence thing good mmm this game is so
our goal is to guess what the right
answer is we will get different points
depending on which if it's the first one
or the tenth option all right huh yeah
no no I don't know I mean yeah sure [ __ ]
all right I don't know what that's such
a who's new starts this game is awesome
what so yes this game is show SZ this
game is rigged a nipple a nipple a
nipple a nipple you go ahead okay yeah
you think you got this yeah I got this I
got this questions okay can should I
stop yes ha ha ha
should I stop come on people are cool
with that that's a very Google a bladder
agreeable thing again a see what because
yeah you do need to stop masturbating
yeah you right now yeah right now the
[ __ ] are you doing put on your pants up
put them on dude there's always like I'm
on stop dancing [ __ ] no what casein okay
okay what drinking of course texting him
we are so bad a texting huh taking birth
control clean vegetarian I like that
being vegetarian is higher than he's not
breastfeeding how'd you get rid of your
how to get rid of your husband it's
pretty good
no you know what how to get rid of yours
it okay yeah yeah pretty solid to freeze
on first point PJ here it comes
oh this is ridiculously hard yeah I want
to know if you guys are getting any
points you get steal my well how will
you ever know like what could have been
that's true well you have to show
results double chin should have been
obvious period fast sister how are we
not gotten a point so far PJ we're
literally the words cuz we suck I'll go
on okay is it possible to fly yeah I was
thinking the same thing thousand why
would you Granville that you 50 is it
possible to fly is it fast no it's me no
absolutely not just I just wanted to
check up yeah is it possible to
yeah that's pretty good oh okay why did
I why would anyone Google a be allergic
to water
dang dry ball a homosexual
no what is gonna be PJ I really wanna
get one now really yeah you want to piss
me up even further
I think my dad is C I want your diet
mine was so much better you'll wipe this
game and [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your dad hey
how's it going guys my name is peach pie
and yeah this is my head we're gonna
keep like Google I love the taste oh
damn egg what
well you spelled his name wrong to stop
today yeah no that's not right that's
how I spell it that you know the effort
e ha ha another 10,000 top 50 J
Shakespeare mother [ __ ] can you these
go alright okay I'll keep playing this
until I get a point okay so I'll be back
at like 10 o'clock I love them [ __ ] it
tomorrow me I'll come back tomorrow
alright
shut up yeah Justin Timberlake yeah I'll
take that I'll take a healthy 9,000 so
how do you spell Bieber okay that's how
you know you don't get that 10,000
points whoa looks like I win a PJ thank
you though for coming along on the [ __ ]
Adam I think so which one did you like
them figures we don't which one does
which was your favor I will those wanted
a face tattoo yeah I'll be like the girl
that woke up with the Stars right yeah I
remember that that woman has been going
down yeah [ __ ] sake
very nice very oh it's like you've never
done this before oh that feels good yeah
go ahead
oh my gosh [ __ ] hell [ __ ] is never
gonna go away oh I think this is how
much [ __ ] I think it's just it's just
generally a messy thing yeah I do that
oh [ __ ] I don't get in your eyes it's it
really hurts my neck right just hold on
for a few more seconds uh okay might
even make me look pretty
hit me up PJ hey got a nice little
dolphin going there hmm
okay I think that's enough group are you
gonna sign it uh yeah Jesus Christ I'm
drying it okay here we go
mom don't look at this video Mon the big
reveal oh just pull it pull like a
band-aid oh look at that that's
beautiful that is a thing of you - holy
[ __ ] I look [ __ ] awesome I know right
oh my god PJ are you jealous
hello a little bit yeah yeah you want
pup here we go oh oh
go okay these look these look good they
look good oh they look good oh oh oh
that is [ __ ] this has been Google feud
PJ thank you for I'm never reminding you
again
google feud has truly put us in a feud
exactly you want to find PJ check out
link in description
PJ pick the PJ that's the one kick the
Peter that's the one
thanks man how are we in front now uh
Joe long in a too long and remember to
live like if you enjoyed the video and
as always as we do it yeah do we kiss
yes are you playing poker goes to [ __ ]
we say you do it you catching it again
it's a driving behind you dude we see
the same poker scene yeah no I love the
sea runs we found me all the same
Pokemon this is so cool this is it his
real or something it's almost like the
Pokemon is there now we just got hit by
a car yeah and we're gonna go to the
front to do some fishing maybe I'll find
some